[Musique]
né à tours en 1850 victor laloux a
marqué l'architecturé française en
réalisant notamment la grande gare
d'orsay à paris mais son empreinte
reste surtout visible dans sa ville de
naissance avec un monument phare de
l'architecturé troisième république un
hôtel de ville particulièrement
imposants
ça correspond à un moment où le pouvoir
politique des conseillers municipaux est
assez fort et justement à travers la
reconstruction de cette hôtesse de ville
on va marquer le triomphe de la
république à la fin du 19e siècle et on
va choisir un bâtiment plutôt imposant
même beaucoup plus imposant que ce qu'on
aurait pensé pour une ville de cette
importance
victor laloux étudié l'architecturé à
l'école des beaux-arts de paris il a
étudié les grands chefs-d'oeuvre des
temps passer et ils réutilisent donc ce
vocabulaire au sein de l'hôtel de ville
est ce qu il sait également aussi à la
basilique saint martin
une basilique dont la construction subit
la redécouverte du tombeau de saint
martin au 19e siècle et qui place victor
laloux au coeur d'une polémique tels que
l'on a pu parler à l'époque d' affaire
dreyfus tourangelle
d'un côté on trouve des catholique très
fervent qui veulent redonner tout son
faste à ce culte de saint martin et
construire une basilique qui s'apparente
à celle qui existait au préalable et qui
était vraiment très très grande une
église de près pèlerinage très
importante d'un autre côté l'atmosphère
était pas propice à la construction de
ce type d'édifice et pour cause puisque
le conseil municipal à cette époque à la
fin du 19e siècle et très anticlérical
et va s'opposer pendant très longtemps à
cette reconstruction
la gare de tours et bien sûr la
troisième contribution de la loue à l'
architecture de sa ville et il en est
une 4e beaucoup plus discrète beaucoup
moins connu sa propre tombe dans le
cimetière de la salle à tournon la loue
donc c'est très tôt préoccupé de sa
gloire éternelle et de sa gloire sur
terre alors la gloire sur terre en
devenant en 1909 membre de l'institut et
la gloire éternelle en réfléchissant
dessinant son propre tombeau près de
trente années avant sa propre mort et
donc le voici
le voici ici
[Musique]